hi my name is bill 20 Cara I'm a consult
about or for research hi I'm Sean Sharon
and I'm a software engineer at Wolfram
research this year we'll be talking
about new features in Mathematica and
improved features in Mathematica in
import-export we'll also be talking
about how you can add your own features
to the Wolfram language to use with
import and export
Roberta Cabot import/export today so
first I will talk about the updates in
these two functions inflation in 11 and
then Shawn will talk about the
extensibility with what do we mean by
that or basically we will show you how
to develop your own core vector how to
extend the framework to support your own
formatting
all right so quick overview what's new
and what's have been improved when it
comes to import/export in version 11
so let me start from new functions these
are actually new functions not not new
formats supported by import/export but
let me quickly explain what what these
are import byte array and export byte
array very similar to import shrink and
export string but
so you basically convert any word from
language expression to to a file format
but instead of generating a file we
create a byte array for you so stream of
bytes importing exporting would would
generate a string this functions export
beta right generates beta ray there's an
example we take the types of formula and
then export it to the PDF and then we
get a byte array and once once you have
that byte array you can get back your
expression by colleague a input byte
array and it will basically give you the
default representation for for PDF so
that that's that that's a graphics
object now this is newly introduced
format we did support PDF for for a long
time but this is animated be a bit
animated PNG
so basically you can now export import
animations to a PNG format the other
nice feature is that you can directly
export manipulate both to PNG and and
also to give an TIFF format there are
nice nice features you can for example
specify how many times your animation
could run through animation animation
repetition functions and there is also
control appearance functions that you
can control whether you want to export
manipulate controls or not notice here I
manipulate controls are exported and in
this case when you specify
quadrilaterals known they are not
another update about PNG there is a
compression level option that allows you
to control the lossless compression
built in the PNG encoding and finally
there is a color map link option that
allows you to generate a pallet color
images again this is the update what for
gift.if and and PNG so you can think
about basically this color map length as
a lossy compression obviously you will
lose a lot of information if you if you
compress it to only two to four or eight
colors but they could think about this
that when you look at the this plot this
is number of colors versus file bad
count obviously you can save a lot of
disk space if you don't care if you for
example you want only eight colors then
that's the way to do it
so we quantize these images behind the
system and that's what happens via
formats link you might be familiar with
the bio formats library open source
library written in Java for that they do
support more
then 145 formats that you basically can
can can read the image data and the
metadata using that library so now we
have something called by a farmer's link
which is a package that allows you to
interact with with bio formats library
due to prices Achra striction z' we
cannot include it in in Mathematica but
it is available on github and here is
the link
what is it useful for well basically you
can now import formats import read
images from formats that are not yet
supported by import framework and here
is an example there is a format called
nifty and and as you can see import
doesn't and doesn't know how to import
it but but now using bio format leaks
I'm extending the the import framework
and and now I can import that file
because I don't have much time I'm gonna
go quite quickly over the next few
formats so M for a new a new format for
for the story in digital audio we do
support both import and export of m4a
files but only on Windows and Mac OS no
support for Linux at least yet and here
the elements of import WM alive well
from machine learning format format
recently introduced to store new
functions from machine learning such as
net graph classifier function and so on
internally it's actually using the hdf5
to store data MX that that this is the
format used by the deep learning
framework MX net it actually uses two
files the JSON file is used to store
topology and the params file is used to
store the data numeric arrays
here is an example you you can export a
recurrent net to specify basically the
JSON file and the AMEX net as a as a
format and then we can nicely visualize
it using that node graph plot element of
import you can visualize what happens
inside that a recurrent Network you be
JSON
another new format that does the format
to efficiently store and retrieve
structured data jason like data to given
such results from various sensors as a
mathematical Association we can export
that data to UB JSON and comparing the
file size that has been created and the
byte count of their objects you see that
this is this is efficiently stored in a
file next geo JSON that's basically open
standard for representing geographical
features simple geographical features
it's useful for exporting Geographics
objects
okay so simple Geographic objects with a
geo marker of champagne city we can
export the up to do JSON
that's how the data are stored this is
the import of the data element and
obviously that does the format that you
can then import in other other packages
then Mathematica three formats that have
very a lot of in common
basically these have configuration file
formats where you store the string csoka
to values they are stored as plain text
so an example again Association
string string key string values is
stored as an indie feel in that way then
the PHP map Association of all foreign
resources is converted to PHP map using
PHP in the format that you may be
quickly skip that I want to talk about
the updates in in the format's image
raster format so give nice speed
improvement in version 11 but single
frame and multiframe give we do have
some new import elements as well for for
give a big improvement in hdf5 format
nice this is a hierarchical format so we
can now nicely visualize it using the
structure graph elemental and we also
have a structure graph legend new data
types are now support that we support
byte array which is corresponds to hdf5
opaque type alright annum compound and
complex types you can you can get it to
data format element data encoding tree
data and Coda's are supported now tended
this is very nice feature take take
elements option allow you to import the
data efficiently you can basically
access partial data from hdf5 using that
syntax and again a nice performance
improvement fits this is this is we
still working on data you see this is
prototype built but a lot to come a lot
of new nice features in fits as well
performance improvement it's quite
significant and finally the last two
formats i wanna mention is CSV comma
separated values and TSV they have been
updated recently that you can export
directly datasets time serious quantity
arise data to both of these formats
we have a number of new import elements
you can directly import datasets as well
new import options filter all skip lines
allow you to control how you want to
actually for example deal with comments
in in in such files definitely overall
stability improvement in the format and
as usual
performance improvement alright so that
was quick overview what's new and what's
improved now Shaun will explain you how
to develop your own I've been
endearingly referring to this part of
the talk as developing your own import
export convertor so I don't have to and
we understand that a Wolfram research we
want to make our technology as expansive
as possible and integrate with as many
technologies as possible but for
whatever reason maybe we don't support
the format yet or there's a lesser-known
format or you have some proprietary data
format inside your company that you want
to use or you want to extend one of our
existing formats for these reasons you
might want to add code to import and
export so you can see that we have many
many formats that we already support but
will never be a stop for the demand of
new formats so to start let's look at
this tutorial so I don't want to go over
too much information that you can find
in a tutorial very easily we have this
notebook available and we posted it on
the slide for this talk on the website
so you can go and get these slides and
see all those additional features that
we didn't get to show before you can
also get all the direct links from here
don't worry about writing these down
because the last slide collects all of
our reference links so in this directory
installation directory system files
formats format you can actually see the
registrations for our formats for these
formats you can actually see the entire
source code in the converted item file
that's located in that directory import
diadem is where we hold the registration
and export dot M is where we hold for
import and an export item is the
registration for export so register
import is the function that you call in
the import export context to add a
function to import
the format is the first argument then
you have a list of rules where the
left-hand side is the element name and
the right-hand side is the function that
gets called so let's go back and
actually take a look at a simple example
of registering a format called WTC so
for WTC so the first thing that you want
to look at is this elements element how
do you tell import when I say import of
this file elements what elements are
available well there's two ways this
could happen the strings on the left
hand side of the rules or it will look
at those left hand side strings and
automatically return those but as you
can see this first element has this
pattern or it could be one of two
different things
it won't recognize these and for that
reason I suggest that you always define
this function called get elements and
list in one place what your element
names are so on the left hand side we
have the element name and then that goes
to an actual function that implements
the converter for you so you'll notice
throughout the talk that I have these
little wolf symbols these are tips and
tricks for what we do inside wolfram
research and how I suggest that you
build your formats so the import
functions that actually get called by
these might look like this the first
thing that you'll notice is there's
always this pattern of the file name and
then any options that get passed to the
converter now up here you'll also notice
that there's this function over here
that doesn't have a name on the left now
this is the outer this is what will
always get called if you want to send
something to a post converter so you'll
notice that there's this list of
elements here which will return
basically some kind of raw data but then
you might have other elements which all
basically build upon one element and
that's this default element at the end
that will get passed to any of these
post importers you'll also notice that
there's a default element option what
this does is tell it when I call import
of just a file this is the element that
it should call whereas this is the
default element that gets passed to any
of these post importers now these can be
different and I'll show you an example
of that
so if we actually run this
there we go now we can actually call
import string of WTC now you'll see that
the default element is going to summary
which basically just gives you a file by
count and you can see that these are the
same right here for data it's based and
now you'll notice that this function
here we can pass the element name in and
it needs to know so one function could
handle two elements but then you need to
tell it which element it's currently
processing the other important tip here
is that you always return a rule from
these functions which are developed or
which are implementing your converters
now raw data is basically just those raw
bytes and as you can see raw data which
is that default element that gets past
the post importers gives the information
to grid which then wraps a styled grid
around it export is much more
straightforward because with import you
have all these elements that you're
going to with export you just have all
these data types that you need to
recognize and then go down to one
specific format so export you might
define multiple definitions which
basically normalize your data in some
way that is recognizable by the function
that writes to the file so in this case
we always want to have a list of lists
so we might say that for a sparse array
you would call normal before passing it
to that there are a few registration
options which are a bit more advanced
and this is where you can really
fine-tune the functionality of your
converter so sources is pretty
straightforward still it just tells it
where it's going to find the source to
actually implement the code so if your
code uses j-link you need to find it
here you can specify the context that
all your functions are going to come
from and it will also look in that
directory that I appointed you to in
this tutorial to look for the source in
there and a function that we use
internally as default sources which will
basically find the file path of those
things if there's one thing that you
take away today it's the function
channel's option is the most important
thing that you use when registering an
import function or export if you do
function channel's file names then
you're going to see that pattern that we
saw above where the first argument is a
file name but is much more efficient if
you have a way to recognize passing a
dream directly to import if possible
always always always implement a stream
function rather than a filename function
the only reason you should implement a
filename function is if you're a library
that you're using explicitly takes a
file name rather than some data and
you'll notice here that basically the
main difference is that this gets passed
an input stream binary format is the
last important option it will determine
the type of stream that is passed to
your converter so if you look at input
stream or output stream they both have
this option called binary and if binary
is true then you're going to be using it
functions like binary read binary write
and that is the main difference here
however there's another important
feature for export when you're writing
bytes of data to a file and it has a
particular encoding typically you would
have to handle that in your converter
but the framework handles this for you
if you set the binary format option then
when it opens the stream that it passes
it to your converter it will open it
with the character encoding option so
all you do is write characters you can
write the string and it will
automatically encode those bytes
correctly and this is one of the reasons
these types of tools are why we
basically do this you could just write
your own converted functions and call
them yourself but then you're going to
lose out on all the functionality that
you get when you integrate with the
framework so next we're going to talk
about the development tools that you
could use and I have to gloss over this
quickly but basically library link and
math linker W STP are definitely going
to be the way that you can do the
fastest IO for getting data back into
Mathematica I highly highly highly
recommend you go to this talk library
link high-performance i/o tips and
tricks where Rafael will talk about how
to use new utilities to build better
library link functions we mentioned that
there's bio formats link on Jake on bio
formats link on github with this you can
actually go and look at our registration
there and see an entire converter that
we built in-house rather recently now
obviously the point of all of this is so
that you can bring your data in and
actually do process
saying with Wolfram language so what you
can do is actually when we invent a
converter we just want to give you the
raw data so that you can play with it
yourself and use your own advanced
functionality when you're developing a
converter you have the option of making
it as rich and expensive as you want
right out of the box this last slide is
basically a collection of these
important links that will get you on the
right track for developing your own
converter thank you we have a few
minutes for questions
sure absolutely that is definitely on
our radar anymore
yeah I did measured about that maybe
very quickly but yes import of hdf5 is
unless you refer to a defect or but but
yes hdf held that therefore but there is
a very efficient way to import partial
data from and we're explaining that the
sports more for more fragments I would
recommend using those to get the
structure for how to build your
converter not necessarily the best
practices for building them but those
formats are kind of lesser used and
they're very small formats so you're not
gonna see a whole lot going on in there
anyway I'm the best thing to look at
would be bio formats link as well as the
examples that you'll see and I guess we
forgot to mention you should really be
paying attention to this github page
because what we're encouraging here is
that as we build these converters these
are things that we can package and
actually distribute so this bio formats
link that we have on github now people
can download and use that so now we
actually have a mechanism for sharing
converters and building import/export
together and not just using the tools
that are out of the box
well we actually don't work on semantic
report there is an other team working on
semantic impose I mean we can definitely
get you in touch with right yeah I mean
we are we are also making updates there
are definitely plans for making semantic
import and import more coupled together
so that they're using kind of the same
backends so when we add stability and
performance improvements down the road
you'll start to see those appearing more
and more in semantic import I can say
that I know somebody is working very
very hard on Excel and it's me so
basically then you're looking at the
connection technologies I wonder if you
actually tried using some of the options
that we have for ERL functions with
import it might just kind of work but we
can talk about that more later if you
want
got time for one more if there is one
great and will definitely be around here
so if you find me I'd be happy to talk
with you more about what we'll be
bringing to the table and help take a
look at some of the things that you're
using import and export for we're very
interested in how you're using this
technology and that'll definitely
influence what we're doing in-house
[Applause]